c'est la saga de l'été sur un scénario
dannemarie catois calcul rois maudits
mais c'est des coups je n'ai rien vu
encore le tournage à lévis en pleine
épidémie de chikungunya
c'était terrible et psychose totale à
psychose totale en lente et beaucoup
beaucoup par parler les nouvelles de
métropole sur un parce que là-bas en
fait ça se vivait très différemment de
ce qu'on pouvait dire ici 1
c'était il y avait et c'est vrai il y
avait il y avait un risque y avait un
danger mais on ce qu'on pouvait se
protéger en étant vigilant et c'est ce
qu'on a tous fait c'était s'était
facilement faire piquer quand même de
temps en temps vous avez été piqué ouais
ouais ouais comme les 5 à 12 jours
d'incubation on comptait les jours parce
qu'on savait pas c'est tellement bizarre
sur les routes c'est tellement bien
qu'on voulu partir il ya eu c'est vrai
un moment une
psychose un petit peu sur sur le
tournage mais il ya eu un grand élan de
solidarité
vraiment tous décidé de rester parce
qu'il y avait quand même faut pas
l'oublier elle est toute une équipe
réunionnaise avait quand même 60 % sont
10% de le réunionnais qui se
retrouvaient planté là si on si on
partait je dirais pas c'est qu'en plus
c'est vrai que pour lille c'était
important aussi qu'on reste parce que ça
a été c'est catastrophique pour
économiquement
moi je devais jouer là-bas les
assurances n'ont pas voulu que je parte
à la suite d'une déclaration d'un d'un
homme politique à la télé où il disait
il ya eu là je sais pas combien de
milliers de gens contaminés et le
journaliste lui disais mais est ce que
est ce qu on a une réponse thérapeutique
et il a dit non il faut qu'on vive avec
le lendemain matin j'avais un coup
téléphone les assurances me disant que
je si je partais je t'ai pas couvert sur
le film et donc voilà j'ai télé j'étais
très malheureux parce que j'aime
beaucoup aller jouer là bas le public
est génial et ça j'étais très triste de
pas pouvoir y aller moi je partais un
mais mais j'imagine
j'imagine l'angoissent que ça pouvait
générer vraiment il y avait l'angoissent
n'y avait vraiment il y avait aussi
beaucoup de bonheur avec là bas aussi
c'était oui et je joue là bas tu fais un
prix au pouvoir d'une cave où il est
resté très courageusement très zen vous
êtes bouddhiste c'est pas pour ça que je
suis m